hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast precision kurtosis
inducers death by liquid peroxidation I
am soon fan of black roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provide our
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
we'd also like to acknowledge the CM
media group for the help with the
programming and promotion of this event
before we start there are few
instructions we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please that's questions or leave us a
comment
answers are welcome to you can do this
by hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can and we'll follow up
if you don't have time for it today
do you want a better look you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
let us know by clicking on the support
button on the lower right or use the Q&A
button and we're trying to make sure
we'll resolve any issues this is an
educational tool a seminar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the CC button located on the bottom
left corner of your webpage and follow
the process of obtaining your credits
now let's get right to today's presenter
we're proud to present dr. Brent
Stockwell dr. Stockwell is a professor
at Columbia University in the Department
of biological sciences and chemistry a
decorated researcher dr. Stockwell is
investigating mechanisms of cell death
and exploring their application in the
treatment of cancer neurodegeneration
his investigations have not only
identified direct candidates
they've inspired new methods of small
molecule drug discovery
dr. Stockwell is author of the quest for
the Cure the science and stories behind
the next generation of medicines the
planners for this event have stated no
relevant financial relationships
however dr. Kevin Davies is a scientific
advisory member board member for the
pathway genomics is on the speaker's
bureau for Harry Walker incorporated and
the other constitutes the conflict of
interest please Matt met dr. Stockwell
has indicated that he has no relevant
financial relationships relative to this
topic I will now turn it over to dr.
Stockwell for his presentation thanks
soon and thanks to lab roots and seeming
news for organizing the meeting today
it's great to be here and talk about
precision medicines and tell you a
little bit about the work we've been
doing on therap totes and how this might
translate into a kind of precision
cancer medicine so why don't we launch
right in and I want to start by
reminding you if you're not familiar
with cell death that cell death is
important in a number of different
diseases like variety of cancers and
regenerative diseases and it's also
naturally involved in the development of
multicellular organisms now a few years
ago we asked the question what is the
full range of cell death mechanism so
could we begin to map out all the
various ways that cells can die
particularly in mammalian cells what
would we want to do this well if we can
define detailed mechanistic ways that
cells actually die we may be able to
create precision medicines that take
advantage of specific dependencies in
particular tumor cells for example and a
good recent example of this is in
chronic lymphocytic leukemia where we
see they're often dependent upon a
specific group of proteins that regulate
a pitocin the anti a platonic proteins
known as bcl-2 and bcl-xl and actually
recent phase 2 clinical studies showed
that these inhibitors were effective in
this type of leukemia and trying to
identify but precise biomarkers that
predict
that sensitivity is still something
that's ongoing now a number of years ago
we noticed and another people in the
cell death cell that field would begin
to observe this as well but there are a
variety of situations where cells die in
degenerative diseases or in response to
therapy but it doesn't look like a
pitocin switch was the most well
described form of regulated cell death
and so we began to wonder if we could
come up with a way to explore the kind
of cell death processes that might
underlie these different circumstances
but in a more systematic way where it
would be possible to examine that in
detail because in each of these
individual situations is often not a
good model system and it's hard to
really figure out what's going on
so the idea we had was that we could do
a global analysis of at least
pharmacologically accessible cell death
mechanisms so if we could assemble
hundreds of thousands of lethal small
molecules and we could classify their
mechanisms of action maybe they would
fall into different groups and those
groups would represent the major kinds
of cell death that are possible at least
in that system and that might reveal the
underlying architecture is shown
schematically here so the cell death
landscape as we call it the range of
possible mechanisms of cell death so we
did that and I'll make a long story
short here and just say that we tested
over 2500 lethal small molecules and we
developed a system we call modulatory
profiling that allows us to quickly
define the mechanism of action that
involves basically taking the leaf of
compound testing it in the presence of
other chemical and genetic modulators
and so that things that the term cell
death in different ways and based on the
pattern of responses we could classify
these lethal compounds so when we did
that we found there were a bunch of
compounds that induced necrosis more of
an unregulated cell death a bunch of
compounds that in
eight vertices this more well described
regulated formula Selva and then there
was this other type of cell death some
kind of distinct but unregulated form of
cell death and so we wanted to figure
out what was going on there what did
that represent in terms of a cell death
mechanism so a bunch of experiments over
a number of years led us to conclude
that this type of regulated cell death
was not a puto Cecilie distinct from a
proptosis but it was an oxidative and
iron dependent form of cell death and if
we looked at a lot of different things
like the genes required the morphology
biochemistry the bioenergetics based on
all these criteria we could say that
this cell death was distinct from what
we were singing with a proptosis or
necrosis or other reported forms of cell
death but that it was indeed an
oxidative and iron dependent form of
cell death so we coined this term ferric
ptosis because of the key role of iron
in executing this so death so we wanted
to know what is the mechanism by which
this process is as activated as
triggered and how is it executed what
really separates life from death in the
case of Farouk ptosis so Scott Dixon who
was a postdoc in my lab at this time
asked this question what triggers for
ptosis Scott I should say is now running
his own lab as an assistant professor at
Stanford in the department of biology so
when Scott was with me we asked this
question and Scott was able to track
down that one way of triggering Farouk
ptosis one set of compounds we had
identified that trigger for ptosis do
this by inhibiting the uptake of
cysteine now cysteine is the oxidized
form of the amino acid cysteine so
that's two cysteines together in a
disulfide ranked form and it turns out
there's a specific what's called an anti
porter in cells called system x c that's
normally responsible
in a number of different cell types for
importing cysteine at the same time this
antiporter exports glutamate now that
will become important later but for now
I'm going to tell you that System XE
takes up cysteine once inside cells
cysteine is reduced to the amino acid
cysteine and then cysteine is used of
course for a lot of different things
including protein synthesis but one
thing that cysteine is used for is to
make the antioxidant tripeptide
glutathione and that turned out to be an
important aspect here so gsh has be
abbreviated or glutathione so we made
this observation based on Scott's work
that a key triggering event was the
depletion of cysteine and specifically
through system XE we had an interesting
mysterious observation at that time we
noticed we had another set of compounds
exemplified by one here shown here in
the slide that we call RS l3 for
historical reasons
now these compounds like RSO 3 could
also induce for up ptosis but they did
not inhibit system XE they did not
inhibit cysteine uptake and they did not
cause depletion of glutathione the way
we saw with that first set of compound
so clearly something different was going
on in the case of RSL 3 at least so once
a yang who was a postdoc in my lab at
the time he's now assistant professor at
st. John's University here in New York
and Ramiro Sri Rama Ratna who is a
graduate student in the lab work
together to try to figure out how is our
SL 3 able to induce Farouk ptosis
because it it activates what looks like
a very similar if not identical form of
cell death except that the triggering
mechanism is clearly different and so we
thought maybe our SL 3 is acting in some
downstream way bypassing the need to
inhibit system XE and induce glutathione
depletion so ramita and hua worked
together on this question and the
strategy was an affinity
purification approach to try to identify
the protein that interacts with our sl3
now we have a couple of things going for
us here one is that RSL for me is very
potent low in animal potency turns out
to be a covalent head there and only one
stereoisomer
of RSL 3 is active the other
stereoisomers two chiral centers are not
active so anyway we were able to
successfully purify the protein that's
targeted by our self 3 using an affinity
reagent based on our soul 3 shown here
and when we did that we found that the
top protein pulled down was a
glutathione dependent peroxidase known
as glutathione peroxidase 4 it was
enriched and we did this in two
different ways and won't go through the
details of the affinity purification but
with very high confidence we identified
this as the target and then we were able
to validate that in a number of
different ways so here's GP x 4 you can
just see the validation by Western blot
it's present on a resin with the active
compound but not if we have a competitor
or an inactive compound and if we look
at GP x for biochemical activity
themselves yes indeed we see that our SL
3 inhibits that activity but an inactive
analog doesn't so all of this led us to
the idea that GPX for this protein this
enzyme is the relevant target of this
compound how does that tell us about
feral ptosis oh and I should say when we
knock down GP x for with RNA
interference reagents we see it's lethal
and it looks just like our SL 3 of the
inhibitor so all these data convinced us
GP x 4 is the relevant target for our SL
3 ok so what is GP x 4 do well it's a
very interesting protein it's a lipid
repair enzyme it's normal job is to go
around looking for lipid peroxides and
damage oxidized lipids in the cell
membrane environment and then
that damage by reducing the peroxide to
an alcohol and since peroxides are
reactive and alcohols are not that
effectively repairs this damage and in
order to repair that damage it uses
glutathione gsh to reduce the peroxide
and in the process glutathione gets
oxidized to me.they sulfide form here so
RS l3 inhibits this and so we get this
accumulation of lipid peroxides in the
presence of RS l3 and so ultimately we
found this is a death by lipid
peroxidation overwhelming accumulation
of these liquid peroxides
because we've inactivated the repair
enzyme okay so at this point we knew
we've got two mechanisms for reducing
ferric ptosis we have the compounds that
inhibit system XE right that's the
uptake of cysteine that then eventually
leads to the depletion of glutathione
because these cells then don't have
cysteine needed to make little fire now
losing glutathione would have a bunch of
different effects themselves but
actually the thing that kills them it
turns out is they don't have glutathione
that's needed for G px4 activity so
ultimately when we deplete glutathione
we lose GPX for activity and then we get
this accumulation of lipid peroxides and
we can achieve this effect either by
inhibiting the uptake of cysteine and
depleting glutathione or by inhibiting
GPX for directly so these were the two
mechanisms we had elucidated for
activating proptosis
okay so now we wanted to know what are
the relevant substrates the relevant
lipids there are hundreds if not
thousands of lipids
different membranes in cells so I'm
going to ask you a question now this is
the audience response portion of the
talk so please type your ideas in the
green Q&A box for what method would you
use or could we use think about this
problem to figure out what are the lipid
substrates that GPX for is acting so and
I see one of the questions that's come
in is what's the potency of RSL three
four
GPX for and yeah that's a good question
it's very potent in both the biochemical
and cellular assays it's in the loan
animal arrange about 59 and more water
potency so go ahead and type in your
questions your ideas about how could we
identify the lipid peroxide substrates
that GPX for is acting on okay so all
those are coming in when I see one now
one idea liquid ohmic profiling so you
could in other words try to use maybe
mass spectrometry to catalog all the
lipids and how they're change that's
Gopi Gandhi from GSK Thank You Coakley
and yeah that's what you would have
thought something like that some kind of
biochemical technique and we've done
some of that and I might be able to get
to that at the end but the strategy we
used here that I want to tell you is
actually a little different from that so
what we ended up doing and this we came
about this in a kind of unexpected way
Scott was at a meeting actually I
believe it was the nature Chemical
Biology symposium in Boston and he ran
into the Ord winter who was a graduate
student in Julio's appeared to ferger's
lab at that time and they started
talking about her up ptosis and other
things and Georg had been developing a
genetic system that could be used to
figure out mechanisms of action of small
molecules and so they thought oh we
could do a genetic screen and try to
learn more about Farouk ptosis and how
these Farouk ptosis induces work so
that's actually why we how we got
started on this and
we'll see where that laughs okay so this
the system that Georg had had set up in
Julio's lab was a haploid genetic
screening system so this is a particular
cell line KB m7 that is basically
haploid except for one chromosome so
they have one copy of each gene and so
in this system you can do insertional
mutagenesis inactivate various genes and
then select the cells to see which ones
can still grow in the presence of a
lethal compound so we did a control
first we took I mentioned the bcl-2
inhibitors in the beginning for induced
apoptosis so we took a bcl-2 inhibitor
the Abbott 263 compound also known as
Nvidia plaques that inactivates bcl-2
proteins and then execute a pitch OSIS
through the BH 2 pro apoptotic proteins
now when we did this screen we selected
four genes that could survive in the
presence of this bcl-2 inhibitor we
found two bcl-2 family genes the
canonical backs and knocks ax and that
when we inactivate those genes the cells
can survive in the presence of the bcl-2
inhibitor so that was a very nice proof
of concept for us that this genetic
screening system would identify key
genes involved in the execution of a
particular cell death mechanism so then
we said well it's just going to give us
maybe some false positive so we then
tested what would be kind of a negative
control so we had identified in the lab
a few years earlier a very potent
microtubule inhibitor that we call PK 3
for power killer 3 that's kind of a name
they came up with and we thought it
would be very hard to rescue cells from
microtubule inhibition because they
don't have their cytoskeleton how are
they going to survive and so indeed when
we do this haploid screen with PK 3 we
don't see any genes come out as
suppressors so there's just really no
way to suppress that soda so then we
went ahead and tested the GP x for
inhibitors in the system and we use two
different ones
cel-3 the active stereoisomer that i
mentioned before that's 1 s 3 r r SL 3
and we used a structurally different GPX
floor inhibitor we had identified called
ml 162 ok and we found a few genes that
were knocked out could suppress each of
these compounds and there were slight
differences but there were 2 main genes
in common to these two acs l 4 and l
peak at 3 and so when we dug into the
literature on these we said aha this
really tells us something very
interesting about ferrule ptosis because
ACS L 4 and L peak at 3 are required to
get polyunsaturated fatty acids into
membranes in cells specifically AC SL 4
is involved in the estera fication of
arachidonic acid and its derivatives
these polyunsaturated fatty acids so
that gives us the ester version that's
hydrophobic and can be inserted into a
membrane and then LP cat 3 does the
insertion into the membrane so these two
genes are required to get
polyunsaturated fatty acids into
membranes this made a lot of sense to us
because polyunsaturated fatty acids are
thought to be and really are very prone
to lipid peroxidation much more so than
saturated or monounsaturated fatty acids
so this suggested the answer to that
question what are the substrates the
substrates are very likely than
polyunsaturated fatty acids derived from
arachidonic acid and if you don't have a
sufficient abundance of those in the
membrane cells are going to be resistant
to thorough doses okay so that's some of
what we've learned about the mechanism
but I want to now turn to this question
of in vivo relevance and
how do we exploit this information and
the design of precision medicine now in
terms of in vivo relevance we can think
about two different ideas that one is
confer kosis actually be induced in vivo
and does it naturally occur in any
context and normal development or in
other diseases now we had a clue that
cirrhosis might be involved in some
diseases because as I mentioned before
system XE which imports is fine and also
exports glutamate and we had seen that
glutamate high concentrations of
glutamate outside the cell will inhibit
system XE and claws for arctos as' and
it turns out glutamate is well known to
be a to be toxic when it accumulates at
high concentrations through different
mechanisms but one potential mechanism
there was the induction of ferric ptosis
by inhibiting system XE and depleting
glutathione in response to glutamate
exposure and glutamate toxicity in
general has been linked to a number of
neurodegenerative diseases
Huntington's traumatic brain injury
number of different diseases and so we
thought if glutamate is acting through
Farook ptosis it might implicate ferb
ptosis early at least partially in the
pathophysiological mechanism of those
diseases okay so how could we answer
this question about the role of varrock
ptosis in these diseases well we thought
what if we could develop a firm ptosis
inhibitor and then test it in models of
glutamate toxicity for example so we
went ahead and we did that and we we did
a screen and we found this compound we
called Faro statin which inhibits
fructose is specifically I won't go
through all the data on that and we
tested it in a model of glutamate
toxicity so you can see that here when
we treat cells with a high concentration
of glutamate we see expensive neuronal
cell death
in a brain slice culture model which is
sort of an ex-vivo semi physiological
model but then if we simultaneously ad
fara statin this which blocks for a
ptosis but doesn't inhibit any other
leaf or compounds we've tested then
indeed we see a protection from
glutamate toxicity and we get the same
kind of effect with an iron key later
showing it's also an iron dependent
process so this suggested that at least
in this model song a glutamate toxicity
can go through this frog ptosis leg or
at least lipid peroxidation mechanism
because we think first Adhan ultimately
blocks the lipid peroxidation okay so
what about a more diseased relevant
models so we worked with Don Lowe and do
two tests first that in a Huntington's
disease brain slice model Huntington's
also involves glutamate toxicity in this
model if you deliver the mutant
huntingtin protein to brain slices to
the striatal region we see extensive
neuronal cell death dradle cell death
and then there positive control in the
assay that can be rescued but if we
treat with Ferriss diet and over here on
the right we see at some micro molar
concentrations very nice protection from
the toxicity of the mutant huntingtin
protein used in this assay so it
suggests that at least again in this
model there may be an element of
Huntington's disease that goes through
this lipid peroxidation possibly Farouk
ptosis like mechanism and we've now
looked at a number of other diseases as
well and we've seen evidence that therap
ptosis may be involved at least in some
models of situation that occurs with
prematurely born infants called
periventricular leukomalacia it's a
white matter region in these kids it's
an oxidative damage that seems very much
like Farouk ptosis some types of kidney
dysfunction we've worked with Andres
Ling come in and he'll Germany on this
and in vitro and in vivo models until
Weinberg and nephrologist that we see
evidence and a numbered
different systems that these
degenerative diseases some of them at
least may go through Farouk ptosis and
[ __ ] can be prevented or rescued by
first patent type compounds okay well
what about the flipside can we induce
Farouk ptosis in tumors and sensitize
tumors for example so we've been working
on optimizing these compounds that we
have the first one is the first
generation were not suitable for testing
in vivo but we've made some improved
compounds that have good potency
stability pharmacokinetics and can be
tested in for example xenograph tumor
models where we implant a tumor into the
flank of a mouse then we begin treating
with a compound and we can see for
example with this analog there's
significant inhibition of tumor growth
when we treat with this fur ptosis and
Newson this is one of the compounds that
inhibit sustained uptake through system
XE but the question we have as we do
these experiments as well which exact
tumors would we target which tumors will
be sensitive which kinds of cancers and
which exact patients ultimately in that
precision medicine model so one strategy
exists empirical let's take a lot of
different cancer cell lines and profile
their sensitivity and see which ones are
sensitive now we did that with the
National Cancer Institute 60 cell line
collection NCI 60 and we found that a
few tumor types were more sensitive in
particular renal cell carcinoma down
here means increased sensitivity up
means more resistant so a number of
kidney cancers or renal cell carcinomas
were particularly sensitive to these
Farrell ptosis inducers well that was
interesting because at the same time we
made the unexpected observation that the
clinically used
anti-cancer drugs are often it which is
used to treat renal cell carcinomas and
some liver cancers actually can induce
farooq ptosis so in the low micromolar
range we see themselves in culture at
least
Saravanan this so-called multi targeted
nice inhibitor inhibits Systemax e
inhibits cysteine uptake and shown here
and glutamate release similar to what we
get with these other compounds they've
been looking at before but other multi
targeted kinase inhibitor is like
imatinib or any other ones we've looked
at don't do this it's something unique
to sur often it and so often have indeed
it depletes glutathione as we would
expect if it's inhibiting system XE and
deprive themselves of cysteine and in
causes lipid peroxidation but right out
by this dye would it be c11 so we know
at least in cell culture so often it has
this ability to induce ferric ptosis so
we thought can we look at patients
treated with Saravanan and see if
there's any signature that sorafenib is
doing something different from the other
multi targeted kinase inhibitors
especially the ones that have very
similar profiles of kinase inhibition
just are often it but that don't induce
rock ptosis so we did that and with Nick
Totten Eddie and biomedical informatics
we found we analyzed 2.9 million patient
records and we found that if we look at
the adverse event profile as kind of a
signature of the bio activity of the
compound then we could see that yellow
here is is active on this adverse event
it's a heat map and we see that so often
it over here on the left has the widest
profile of adverse events even though
these are the kinase inhibitors again
have similar profiles and so it suggests
to us that Saravanan is doing something
extra in these patients that's
manifesting as this idiosyncratic kind
of interaction with various factors that
gives them a different adverse event
profile so maybe that additional thing
that Saravanan is doing in patients is
inducing therap ptosis and maybe that's
contributing to the clinical efficacy
but that is still speculation okay so
now we're going to do one more audience
response I want to ask you at this point
if we you had to predict the
molecular predictor of sensitivity to
ferric ptosis what would it be in other
words if we want to pick out the
particular renal cell cancers or other
cancers that we're going to be sensitive
or resistant could we make a guess based
on what we know about the mechanism at
this point which molecular factor would
be most sensitive so you can go ahead
and take that into your box into the Q&A
box and I'll go ahead and take a look at
the comments as they come in and I'll
say that it's often in retrospect when
we eventually find the biomarker here
the predictor we can kind of rationalize
it but it can be difficult to try to
figure this out in advance so to look at
the pathway look at the mechanism and
guess what it is so let's see if any
anyone has any thoughts about the best
yeah
Oh a good coffee someone said a good
coffee would be needed yes to think
about this scratch your head roll up
your sleeves okay so one idea from haiti
aki Okoboji UCSF is lipid peroxides
themselves and that would be maybe the
basal level of lipid peroxidation could
be a predictor that is a very
interesting idea and we haven't been
able to really test that yet because we
don't have good ways of detecting lipid
peroxidation in vivo but as we develop
better reagent
I would love to test that idea because I
think that's a good suggestion another
suggestion from a Nastasia supernova as
upregulation of GPX for yes and we
actually have seen that there is some
correlation with GPX for across
sensitive and resistant cells in the
sense that the more GPX for you have
especially at the upper end of
expression you begin to be resistant to
fur up ptosis and that makes sense is
more of the enzyme so you need more drug
to inhibit it okay well let me tell you
about what we did to try to answer this
question while some more people are
thinking about
ideas so Kenichi Shimada was a graduate
student in my lab he's now a postdoc
with Tim mitchison at Harvard Medical
School
and so Kenichi analyzed the NCI 60
that's the 60 cancer cell lines we had
tested I mentioned before at the
National Cancer Institute and we had
from their data all the expression
profiles at mRNA levels in all those
cells and Kenichi found that NADPH
utilizing genes their expression
correlated with sensitivity to furrow
ptosis and when he looked in more detail
in fact NADPH abundance itself predicted
actually resistance to Farrell ptosis
low NADPH sensitivity high NADPH
resistance and this was a very good
predictor across these cancer cell lines
then we looked in another couple hundred
with the brave Institute and we found
that predictor held even in that second
totally independent data set so NADPH
what is NADPH NADPH is basically the
ultimate source of reducing power of
cells so it provides the ability to
carry out this reduction of lipid
peroxides because in the end that
reducing power comes from NADPH so makes
sense that if cells have more NADPH they
would be more resistant and if they have
low levels of NADPH they kind of exhaust
their reducing reservoir and then they
become overwhelmed by this lipid
peroxidation
at least that's one idea right now as to
why NADPH is a good predictive and this
paper actually just appeared a few days
ago in cell chemical biology if you want
to look at more details about that now
I'm going to tell you one other approach
we use to identify biomarkers because as
good as any dphh it's not the perfect
predictor so Mickey hayano was a
graduate student in my lab and she did a
genome-wide RNAi interference screen so
she wanted to find genes that when
knocked down would cause resistance to
Farouk ptosis and she found indeed one
in particular when knocked down cars
suppressed
farik ptosis and here you can see that
the knockdown of cars and significant
effect on growth inhibition by a
ferocious inducer and at the protein
level up here in the upper right knock
down a card now we saw white cars
what does car is doing well it turns out
that it's not knocking down cars per se
it's not cars but it's the response to
knocking down cars that was the key
because cars is the sistine o trna
synthetase and when cars is knocked down
cells respond by up regulating the
so-called transyl for a ssin pathway
that's a way that cells can make
cysteine from the thiamine and bypass
the need for system X in other words
they're making their own cysteine they
don't need to import it they can get it
from the thiamine and so they become
resistant so this turns out to be a
great predictor and that's another those
are two key ways that now we can predict
which tumors will be sensitive or
resistant I want to just thank again
members of my laboratory as I wrap up
here I mentioned some of the key people
who worked on these projects I also want
to thank these different organization
these different collaborators many of
them who I mentioned who played a role
here these organizations for funding and
then I want to leave you with this slide
which is the sort of a map of our
current understanding of Farouk ptosis
so the the translation pathway I touched
on in the end there is this way that we
can cells can make cysteine from a
thiamine and when that pathway is active
they don't need to import cysteine
through system XE over here but again
the normal way we think about Farook
ptosis now is that if we inhibit system
XE with glutamate or these compounds or
our students are often have another
fda-approved drug that's use sometimes
it's sulfasalazine then in all these
cases we see the depletion of cysteine
and cysteine and glutathione but the key
effect is the loss of GPX for activity
and then we get that overwhelming lipid
peroxidation and that process can be
inhibited by thorough statins and now
some other inhibitors are known by
tammany you know high levels of NADPH
protect and we know that in terms of
getting the substrates in there the
lipid substrates we need a CSF for an LP
cat3 in order to enable therap ptosis to
operate in those cells so thanks again
and I'm happy to take questions they say
we have a few questions coming in here
so let me let me pull up some of these
questions okay have we done so gopi
gonji from GSK asks us have you done any
cell line screens with RSL 3 is it
barley cytotoxic or does it work work in
certain contexts so yeah we have profile
RSL 3 across a range a few hundred
information to us before we get started
with all of your questions here's a
quick reminder about how to reach us
today questions can be sent via the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll get to as
many questions as we can and as friend
started to ask the question the first
question read it again and I'll go fee
from GSK asks have you done any cell
line screens with RSL 3 is it broadly
cytotoxic or work with certain context
okay great sorry I got excited there to
start answering the questions and I
jumped right in yeah
so we have looked across a few hundred
cancer cell lines and there's a subset
of cell lines that are very sensitive
there's a few later intermediate and
then there quite a few that are
resistant and we think these different
factors drive that but there may be
other factors so it doesn't seem to be
like a general cytotoxin but you have to
have the right cell context for tumors
to be sensitive the right amount of
polyunsaturated fatty acids abundance of
iron and all of these various factors so
it does seem that there is a subset of
tumors that are going to be much more
sensitive to this compound and soon are
you going to read each question or
should I pick them out that's an
interesting question on general culture
conditions I mean we've looked at a few
different aspects of culture conditions
so changing serum I think in general
when you have less serum so do become
more sensitive to most compounds I don't
remember any particular effect but I
would suspect if I went back and checked
we'd seen as some enhanced sensitivity
in row serum also we've looked at oxygen
levels which you might be thinking about
because turns out it's very interesting
oxygen normally in the atmosphere around
us is about 21% but in our bodies
physiologically and in tumors it's in
the ranges we have one to seven percent
depending on the tissue and tumor how
hypoxic it is and so we wondered if
Farook ptosis would only work in these
cell culture conditions where there's a
lot of oxygen but would it work
oxygen levels and so we actually have a
chamber where we can type a hypoxic and
chamber we can titrate the level of
oxygen very precisely and we find that
if we go to like extremely low levels of
oxygen under 1% there's a bit of
resistance but in general even at these
low oxygen levels cells are still
sensitive so the culture conditions
don't seem to matter too much in terms
of the sensitivity that was great
next we have Victoria who asked have you
looked at the interface between gsh and
other cellular antioxidants Mullane
acidic pathways well we haven't looked
at melanocytes particularly but we we
have looked a bit at other antioxidant
not not too much though actually there
would be it would be interesting to dig
into that in more detail but one thing
we have noticed is that vitamin E is an
important regulator of sensitivity so if
we add a lot of vitamin E alpha
tocopherol to cell culture for example
cells become very resistant and we have
some evidence that if you perturb
vitamin E levels natural levels and that
could change the sensitivity to
varicoses so based on that I would say
that probably the level of at least
lipophilic antioxidants in cells would
change sensitivity to Farook ptosis in
terms of other antioxidant systems I
think that's still an active area of
exploration there's some idea that now
that nrf2 the antioxidant master
regulator may drive resistance to Farouk
ptosis and there may be other players
but that's kind of still relatively wide
open
and we have lots of great questions
coming in our next question comes from
Jeremy at USAA
whereas if Q as PFA is involved in fair
ptosis what do you see what do you see
use of fish oil would affect cancer
treatment that's a great question
actually I think that there's a really
an untapped area that we want to start
to look at which is the interaction
between nutrients and nutrition even
diet and response to cancer therapy
particularly in the case of farik ptosis
where it's so tight into metabolism so
in particular if you were to supplement
with polyunsaturated fatty acids omega-3
fatty acid eat your fish because your
omega threes then you should drive
sensitivity to fare up ptosis so if we
have a drug that induces ferb ptosis
we're going to want those patients to
the extent we can do this on high levels
of polyunsaturated fatty acids now we
haven't tested that in an animal model
experimentally but certainly that that
is one idea that you could modulate the
sensitivity and particularly if there's
a distribution of those nutrients like
polyunsaturated fatty acids into the
tumor then it should even more so
increase the therapeutic index so I
think that's another great area that we
should be looking at
great next we have a question from Jay
pronounced University who asked in
seracote's
[ __ ] expression that exists in his genes
yeah we haven't seen too much in terms
of co-regulated expression for these
different proptosis modulators I would
say the one exception I alluded to nrf2
so there was a paper showing that the
master regulator antioxidant driving
transcription factor nrf2 drives
resistance to ferric ptosis and so that
may coordinate the expression of a
number of genes that prevent Farokh
ptosis so that would be one example but
other than that not aware of a kind of
coordinated regulation of the genes at
thanks Murray
appreciate the question so it's a good
question actually and for awhile there
was speculation that maybe necroptosis
which is a kind of regulated necrosis as
it's been described would share some
similarities to therap ptosis and so we
and other people had looked into that we
don't see any evidence for that they
seem really completely distinct in terms
of the molecular regulation the thing
that changed sensitivity the factor
everything we can see so we we also
looked very extensively at a pitocin so
if we look at the genes that control a
pertussis those don't overlap at all
it's a totally different set of genes
compared to the ones that control
Thurrock ptosis so at least in terms of
a pitocin necroptosis and Farrell ptosis
they're really very distinct processes
and I think it makes sense because a
pitocin is ultimately death by
proteolysis to activate caspase-3 aces
that cleave proteins farooq ptosis is
death by lipid peroxidation and so the
things that regulate those two they're
very different processes are not not
going to overlap thanks Asia
thank you are there any specific changes
in the cells that drive keratosis for
example like the effects of hypoxia on
brain cells in the premature born
children or what drives what triggers
for ptosis in general yeah I think
that's a great question Nastasia so a
lot of times I mean in culture we can
induce farik ptosis and we know the
trigger but if what you're saying is
right I mean in different disease models
if it's response to cancer therapy
that's one thing we know the trigger but
in different disease models where we're
saying farik ptosis may get turned on
what's the actual trigger so we know one
trigger can be glutamate so glutamate
inhibits sustained uptake and it's
acting just like these system XE
inhibitors attacking at the level of
cysteine optic so that's that's one
trigger that could be there but it's
probably not the only trigger another
idea and we don't have a lot of evidence
for this specifically being the trigger
but in in in kidney degeneration for
example if you get you get muscle
wasting and that releases large amounts
of myoglobin and then the iron that's
released by myoglobin gets recirculated
or filtered by the kidney so the first
cells in the kidney the proximal renal
tubules cells are exposed to this very
high iron
beyond what they normally would see and
so when that happens there's basically
this bolus of iron and so we think that
iron like high levels of iron a bolus of
iron might be a trigger because that
could then drive through either
enzymatic or non enzymatic mechanisms so
a high level of lipid peroxidation that
overwhelms the normal homeostatic lipid
peroxidation repair that was happening
in those cells and that just drives me
past the point where it can be repaired
and into therap ptosis again assuming
all the other context is right you've
got the poly unsaturated fatty acids and
everything else that high iron could be
a trigger you think that's possibly
involved in some neurodegenerative
diseases that have accumulation of iron
as well but you know I think these are
still very much open questions in terms
of what the different triggers are in
these diseases
okay I think we're gonna have maybe one
more question and I think there's a
technical delay so maybe I'll just jump
in and ask the question myself some
Diego Qian on bass
Coronel and know if I'm pronouncing that
correctly but from Central University
says do you have any experience using
softener in ovarian cancer well that's
an interesting question for two reasons
so first no we actually don't have
experience using sera infinite per se
ovarian cancer and as far as I know only
used clinically for renal cell carcinoma
and hepatocellular carcinoma under
certain circumstances and I think truth
be told and we know it's being surpassed
by some other newer agents that are
coming out although I believe it's still
used in I've had a cellular carcinoma
not so much in ovarian though but having
said that one of the sensitive tumors
when we profiled a number of different
cancers actually was ovarian to ferric
ptosis induces not Saravanan we didn't
look at that per se but other like the
ones that induce inhibit system XE and
GP x for inhibitors were quite potent in
a number of ovarian cancer cell lines so
it's not something we've really pursued
but I think if one is interested in
ovarian cancer that they might have an
intrinsic sensitivity to therap ptosis
so it'd be worth looking at sera
phonetic and other agents as they come
along so is I don't know if we can get
soon back on line and then
to once again thank you for such a
fantastic presentation do you have any
final comments for us great well it's
been great being here I really enjoyed
the format I love the topic and I
appreciate the audience being
interactive and coming in with your
questions so if you have more questions
about syrup ptosis in the future feel
free to get in touch with me and thanks
again to the organizers for having me I
just wanted to let the audience know
that today's black-white press will be
available for on-demand viewing through
August of 2016 you may receive an email
from us alerting you when it's available
for on-demand viewing and posted on
libraries you're welcome to forward this
email to any colleague who weren't able
to join in today thanks again for
logging in and we hope to see you again
soon